[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
set me free
[Music]
ah
combination A7 yep let's go
it's been moved
I've got it
[Music]
what are you doing
I had it come on
yeah we're so good I'm doubled
legendary defense player hey
let's go
Faster come on
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh okay
[Music]
huh thank you
see you tomorrow
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
this will be easy
[Music]
ah good he's a chopper
this will be easy
ah
[Music]
okay that's mine no and drop shot
all right thanks very much yeah thank
you
[Music]
O'Connor show your Rockets okay
sensor oh that means it's official yeah
level
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I wonder where the Umpire is oh yeah
hello
[Music]
yeah yeah
yes come on still leading
yeah good call I also think that should
be around
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
what's wrong nothing 100 RV URS are
subscribe to our channel so it's a very
good day yes
[Music]
Emma what's wrong only 18 of our viewers
are subscribed to our Channel we could
have 10 million subscribers if everybody
would subscribe well let's hope our
viewers who aren't subscribed will do it
now click subscribe right now
heart and then slow
[Music]
why
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
up